hey guys i'm ryan right hey guys i'm
salamander so sally and i we're gonna
check out a video today of Johnny dude
this surprises sick children in
Australian hospital as Jack Sparrow
ba-bam I'm so excited I'm going to
surprise some children outside donor if
there's gonna make me cry scared
I don't like actually you know I like
crying
okay fine be open yeah you know I'm
gonna open up my heart yeah yeah cuz I
do like crying it does feel good just to
get it all out yeah let's so does
ejaculation same same exact stimulation
mmm same thing sometimes the jackal II
then cry I don't know want to talk to
you as if I'm giving you advice I can't
do it Nick
Jack you late and I cry feels amazing
totally stress-free taken to the roof
yes and the Children's Hospital
[Music]
yesterday lovely punch he's like the
coolest celebrity of all die baby jingle
in the pocket what did you ever lovely
how do you do now if there's other
people in it why do you call it a selfie
what is that what is that did you smile
no you didn't know you didn't smile at
all you did not smile all right let's
mile to know I have no idea what this
thing is I have in my hand but I've got
it Nicky
obviously but I just wanted to say thank
you to Juicy vie for having me on
I've had a wonderful time I've had a
fantastic time meeting all the all the
kids and everyone in the parents and the
people and all that and I stole a lot of
things and I want to salute you all of
you for your bravery and your courage
because that is all that matters
you can't even I wet myself that's how
happy I know Johnny [ __ ] Johnny Depp
man I want me so food let's have happy I
say that he earned sexy points for sure
what a Children's Hospital told no I
mean the guy is so kind cuz he's I
remember he did something similar wit as
Jack Sparrow you went to a girls school
yes I remember that that was really cute
he's like what Michael Jackson could
have been with kids you know yeah
honestly if I were him and I could
I do it every weekend I just find a
children's hospital or a school and just
show up and like meet him at me weird
[ __ ] no no what would you do at the
Children's Hospital I would just if I
were him if you were Johnny - Oh Jack
Sparrow okay you gotta give the guy
kudos he does how to stay in character
hey I'm off your topic now um never
moved on he knows how to stay in
character really well I mean he's played
the role like five times then you know
what - I just thought this either he is
really selfless and really just wants to
make kids happy are they're promoting
this or this is a brilliant way to
promote the next Pirates of the
Caribbean it's both like yeah probably
told him this idea was like yeah sure I
love kids but also like the fifth one's
gonna be going out cuz he goes out as
not Johnny Depp but as Jack Sparrow and
it made me go I want to see Jack Sparrow
yeah you know made me love him all over
again
do I take the road of love or do I take
the road of unnecessary malice and and
what's the word I'm looking for you know
just like anger towards a theory always
take the road of love cuz I Johnny Depp
would say and that he pissed himself
really like that line then expecting it
I know
anyway gents and wenches if you're new
to the channel you can subscribe to the
real rejects you can check out
salamander Sally's channel on the Sally
Sally Channel and Sally and I just did a
sketch that is on this channel called in
between takes with Ryan and Sally check
it it will change the way you look at us
mm-hmm you're gonna watch it and then
you're gonna watch this video again and
be like whoa I have a completely new
outlook on these two people yeah really
eye-opening anyway and you can follow us
on Facebook Instagram Twitter vine and
periscope and go on my channel because I
uploaded
um ariana grande and it's weird Yassin
Muhammad I'm respectful to all hey Ryan
I mean II love your videos can i have a
shout out your videos make me laugh and
inspire me to be proud of myself as that
what i help you do help you feel proud
of yourself think you're not him
also i am the only subscriber who is
Muslim so what's okay to use that was
name like okay Muslim we got Muslim
territory now what is it about Muslims
that people are talking about now war or
something
I feel like we got a good Muslim joke
for you here yatin Jason you're awesome
that's the best it's the best I could do
I don't know um yeah soon yes I'm in
America it's I love it
in America it's mainly Christians and
your first name is yah sin notes in it's
sin you seen yeah to sin see you aren't
Christian this is a Muslim [ __ ] in the
corner like picking creamy get shot
we're not gonna get shot we didn't
mention the cartel or something oh yeah
there was that is it took your we're
nowhere good doesn't matter